yes let's give a shout out to eric who's
also streaming the match um
all right i think we're good um thank
you very much for waiting everybody a
little bit of a delay
but it's the first match so that's the
way it's gonna be um yeah so as i said
we've got florida or chicago
starting today and then it's gonna run
for the next week 13 matches
i'm starting with this one international
master john lockwick representing
florida
international master grossman
representing chicago thank you
guys for playing how are you feeling
ahead of the match feeling good
feeling relaxed
i'll admit i didn't get too much sleep
last night but i have
i've cold brew so some caffeine to to
keep me awake
all right how about you john are you are
you ready to play
yeah i worked last night so i'm also
pretty tired but
uh you know i just i i wing chess in
general so
all right i'll be fine we got some
entire masters playing but uh
very strong and john you mentioned that
you're not really uh
known for doing too much specific
preparation how about you you have your
systems or did you prepare something for
john here
um that's a good question i prepared by
watching some of the um these carlson
games from earlier
carlson played i think three londons so
i feel inspired
okay john's gonna have to come up with
something that's eleven you've
eric's very well known for that you've
made some videos on
yeah um actually so last night was
monumental my uh
the first video i ever made on the st
louis chess club channel
on the london passed 1 million views so
um congratulations yeah so so one
million people know my
my secret preparation but okay or is
this one person who couldn't learn it i
kept on watching it like a million times
that's also possible yeah you never know
all right guys um yeah we're really
looking forward to it so the format is
going to be 11 3-minute games followed
by 10 one-minute games
um even if the match is clinched ahead
of time we'll have every game played
um and each game is going to count
towards the final
match standings between florida and
chicago so we're looking forward to it
there will be a short break between
the blitz and the bullet and both
players can call a uh
a timeout at some point during both the
blitz and the bullet i also want to give
a shout out before we start
two uh the chicago chess blitzers and
the national blitz league
we are organizing these matches um in
collaboration with with those guys so
let's give a shout out to them shout out
to eric as well for playing and for
streaming the match and uh
yeah i just want to wish everybody good
luck and uh yeah have some fun games
thanks so much all right good luck eric
thanks
you too so uh
thanks everyone for being patient and uh
and staying here um if you're just
joining
the matches i guess about to start
i should probably send the first
challenge
do i make it rated i'll make it raided
then there'll be more motivation so the
format
is 11 games of three minutes
and then 10 games of one minute
uh let's see what he plays against the
london
london time
yeah and just a disclaimer i won't
really be looking too much at the chat
um but i'll try and offer commentary we
have a main line london
um i'm gonna play this oh
i think he knows that i play this
actually before the stream started uh
we were talking about this line there's
a carlson boccio church game
oh it's funny he's going into it b6
so bossy occ played b6 against carlson
and lost like very terribly
um these moves are also playable
i think against both moves there's 95.
it's also e4 maybe at least against
knight f5
okay this is nice this is like the very
first video of my london course
actually the so my the first video is
free on youtube
on the ihs channel okay so the line here
is
takes and then if takes i can take on d8
there's a nice trap if bishop f2 king f2
rook here and then i just play c6
and it's very good
um and then okay f5 is like the
wait does c6 just win
oh yeah there's an id5 but c6 is very
strong here
um
all right let me try and stay focused
position is like very very good
probably won the queenside castle
so i'm pinning the knife threatening c4
uh now i can probably take i also have
a c4 doesn't quite work or does it
um c4 doesn't quite work
so i'll just take and play knight d4 i'm
holding on to the pawn
this is a very nice start
going for f5 yeah carlson had a very
very similar position
where the knight can't really be removed
and
i think carlson ended up winning by just
pushing the queen cytons
black eventually resigned
f5 is also a threat so rook c8 f5 traps
the bishop
so probably bishop c8 would be expected
play this move
maybe this move
idea i'm just applying even more
pressure
so i'm up upon it's good knight versus
bad bishop
now the bishop's pinned f5 is coming
if g6 is probably g4
also maybe i can just take everything
but there's no need no need to take a
pin piece
yeah there's not even f6 because then i
take
yeah so this game was basically like i
didn't really need to to think so much
um wait f
okay now i need to think a little bit f5
takes takes i'm gonna have c7
c7 is a nice move now rook d7 i check
and win the bishop
okay that was really nice that was just
pure pure opening preparation
uh basically all the way through c6
okay so i was only in the first game
um do i play a stafford gambit
let's start with sicilian
i'm expecting g3 yeah i checked a few of
his games
i know e5 at some points
there's also d5 let's play e5
and then it's sometimes a question if i
want to play
d5 or just d6 and this is a typical
idea for white yeah probably just d6
d5 would probably lose a pawn
okay what's the plan here
play rookie i might just slow play this
like bishop f8
g6 bishop g7
especially if the knight comes here i
want to control f5
with the pawn
and that's likely to happen
i'll probably throw in like h6 g6
i don't think i'm too scared about this
bishop g5 i probably play h6 first
and then bishop g7
because i didn't want to allow queen d2
now the bishop moves back i play bishop
g7 imagine
yeah like queen c1 king h7 there's g5 in
the end
um i can probably take
i could also play g5 myself which is
interesting
um g5 allows
allows too many things
okay so i'm i'm allowing white to play
g5
or basically getting this position
it feels okay idea queen d7
the rook actually might want to go to h8
yeah like rookie chain immediately
at some point white will play h4 okay
king g is coming
i wants to play h5 maybe
let's play queen d7 first
so essentially i'm i'm on castling king
goes to g8
uh and i'll try and try and pressure the
the king side just a little bit
white could consider taking knight g5
and probably kg7 this pawn is a
it's kind of a strength but it's also
okay it's also a weapon
so what if i just take twice
i guess i'll find out so f6 will
nicely kind of restrict the miners
um clever
you probably have six here
and then something something like rook
eight
so the only thing i don't like is my
king
hmm
the king is really awkward
try this move
gotta play faster
usually the king might just run to the
queen side
weirdly enough okay we're dancing around
a little bit
i like my bishop
now i don't know if i like my bishop
that was a bad move by me
not looking good but anything can happen
i think with check
oh good move
[Music]
ugh
no like i made it oh oh king e6 was not
a good choice for the game
okay rematch okay life goes on
um yeah
i got too long time there let's repeat
the same opening
i felt good after that first game
expecting queen c7 now
okay so more london prep idea bishop d3
and e4
queen c7 back
i don't think that really changes things
for me
i'm black might play e5 the e4 yeah so
e4 is a main
idea uh next c5 could be coming
a knight c5 bishop b5 check
like here here and then e5 is hard to
stop
oh that makes sense so knight c5
probably in the very end
i could take with bishop actually
let's stick with bishop also thanks for
subbing
the true salami appreciate that
yeah tts is off but um
alerts are still on side bishop c2
i'm not sure if i if i want to castle
queenside or kingside
i know i want to play queen e2 and stay
flexible and yvonne
kirkovich thanks for subbing
definitely want to maintain the pace
and stay up on time
okay probably eventually 95.
yeah i think the king will be oh i
didn't see that move
that's a good move uh maybe queen e5
there's also bishop a4 weird move
probably not that great though i'll play
queen e5
so knight d3 can't be played um
and once my knight comes to e5 i control
d3
i was thinking the king like if i can
get castled
the king should be safe on b1 um
okay but now it's just going to be
positional
the pawn will be nice on f3 to restrict
the knight
prepares g4 as well let's play this move
threatening this
i take out f no i can't take on f7 yet
there's b4 which is interesting
looks a little bit weakening but i'm
chasing the light back
and the idea is to take on f7 i hear and
take
i think it works
because my knight always is going to
have d6 in the end
oh c3 is weak yeah this is a drawback of
playing
before maybe i can play
liking b2 first
it's a little bit risky i'm allowing
this but i'm assuming
also allowing that to
made some bad assumptions
oh what's going on
so i'm starting to win the knight
allowing this idea rook t3
i think it's okay the lights actually
like
has a lot of potential to cause damage
because like this will be a double
threat looking at the line here
here here here a6 takes
and then 96 f5 and then i take g7 when
e6
yeah i think it's going to play out
oh there's rook f8 opponent doesn't play
it
ah there's that move i can take on g7
still
the 95 doesn't work
because of this move here
here this is nice
i'll take and defend the night in the
event of this
okay another nice kind of london win
okay yeah i have the chat closed but
uh yeah thanks people and people who
subbed
do i play saffron gambit let's play
stafford gambit i'm just curious
oh oh it's four nights let's play this
move
i insist on stafford
i very much insist
oh opponent doesn't do it so i could
play
i guess we're gonna have an italian
i don't know if there's any benefit like
i've delayed
delayed this move maybe i could have
considered that
but okay
oh this is just a four nights
yeah this is like super symmetrical
chess let's make it slightly
asymmetrical idea c6 knight g6
if bishop g5 all i'll probably play c6
and just allow the
the trade also thanks for subbing neon
jar
neon jer solving for eight months
all right so
continue
yeah so far time management has been
pretty good
i feel like the these openings have been
solid
so opponent wants to play bishop bishop
e3
which i can probably allow
i'm actually considering playing b5
there's a small trick like b5 takes and
then knight f4
intermeso forcing queen f1 and then i
take
about the pawns hanging in the end
thanks for subbing the queued
for 7 months thanks so much
bishop d2 i'll play b5
i like b5 it's one of these moves i'll
i'll play regardless
i'm delaying castling because yeah
because of g4 potential
g3 is a bit strange but playable
you can play a5 here
just creating some pressure
okay now i think i want to play digit e6
because if the knight's going to come
here then i want a pawn restricting the
knight
now probably castling
[Music]
wants to attack if i take
i have a weird move
weird move knight h8 idea knight f7
opponent one's g4
i guess i've kind of committed myself
though if g4 will probably move back
um this is kind of a game of cat and
mouse there's also this idea
and girl gay seven is useful here
okay time time will be very relevant
okay now i play this
yeah so the idea with this is now i can
control g5
i don't know if that's a good plan but
it's something
oh that's a good move
back f4 might be coming
yeah the light really wants to re-enter
the game
maybe b4 immediately and then i'll just
play b3
because now there's potential some
potential for initiative
especially with the time situation
initiative is so important
and b3 is a big target and then b2 will
be a target
i don't care about my center pawns i
care about mating and maybe flagging him
i can take this
getting this
get the queen in
good move
okay nice finally reentering the game
a lot of things attacked here
okay that was nice i feel like that was
a better
better quality time scramble than the
previous game is black
all right life continues
i'll just keep flying london i mean
assuming
it keeps working i have to redeem myself
from the the previous uh a previous
match against levy
thanks for subbing joro
dora lust um
weird play this move
and this
also thanks for subbing oh thanks for
the bits lord andy goods
i appreciate that
so c5 could come
let's start with start with this
oh if only i can get a knight on c6
so c5 is coming
i'm curious the best approach here
c3 there's knight b3
it's actually a cool idea to play e4
i don't know if it works but it looks
cool
the e4 and then 95 i'm gonna try it
i spend way too much time there
so the basic idea is after it takes 95
oh there's just bishop b7
wow interesting
okay so i'm threatening to trap the
queen
and this should be saturn most likely or
even
no black can't take any pawn okay that's
a move
so we could trade
i'm gonna be down the pawn
and just down upon
okay we can trade queens
i kind of botched this i'll play queen
g4
maybe it's not so bad i'll have the d
file
but the problem with rook d1 is i lose
a5
so i have to be a little bit controlled
so i'm calculating bishop d5 rook t1
queen a5 takes takes takes b3 c3
queen a1
actually don't know what's going on
there maybe rook d1 takes b2 e6
because it takes queen g6 here it's very
close to mating
watch us enter that line we might enter
the line wow
i think we're entering the line so the
variation is yeah we're entering this
exact variation
so the whole idea is e6 which i'm hoping
works c3 is defended
this is why you should calculate on your
opponent's time
i don't know if this works though
because black doesn't have to take
i don't know what my thread is maybe
thread is takes rook d7
i probably just have to castle
maybe this i don't know
at least my king is safer than box king
interesting oh so my queen is glued to
c3
i probably don't want to lose c3 so
since the question do i take
first let's play this e4 will be juicy
and if takes i probably just castle and
then winnie for the next move
[Music]
oh
i'll admit i forgot about f5 but f3
could be coming
what's going on here
i'd like to take
maybe bishop g5 oh my time
ah it's very close to mating though
because this pawn on e6 is
such a monster calibrating bishop e7
queen c5
uh let me do this in queen c1
and bishop defends the pond forever
king activity
now it's just about meeting
okay that was nice that was a fun game
wow this uh
i'm proud of finding this e6 idea before
it even happened
it was like one of those lines which
just kind of flow
let's repeat the same opening i'll try
and get a stafford
waiting for this move
and this is a long match at some point
i'll take the pawn
i think this is nice and blitz too
because like clearly he's not prepared
meanwhile i'm just like the amount of
time i'll get from this opening is is
well worth
losing upon like even if he figures out
how to refute it
queen e2 is not the refutation i don't
think
uh i'll play a6 because i i don't want
to allow knight a4 after d6
i could even castle and go for d5
the problem is g4
a g4 g5 is actually kind of annoying
envisioning like d4 maybe
let me go play maybe i should hold off
d4 takes takes
hmm
let's go for this it's gonna be very
similar to the the previous game
okay i assumed this but that was a bad
assumption because takes
and so now i'm i'm the one down on time
it's an interesting position though
i think i'll i'll do some maneuvering
thanks for subbing oh ali ram and
oe jizu both subbing
new subs thanks so much
so these squares are very juicy for for
a night maybe for both nights
um in h6
f4 is the juiciest with d4 there's
trading
ideas or c3 ideas later but f4 there's
no
there's no white pawn that can control
f4 these pawns are
a bit over pushed
and the queen is a nice target
okay so there's some tension white
probably wants to castle
queen side so let's play b5 or maybe c6
first
ah there's d4 as an idea
actually d4 is kind of annoying
huh
oh wow maybe i over pushed
if i take don't want to take
not seeing what to do here
[Music]
actually maybe this move it might just
lose a pawn
that was kind of a panic move
let's take here first and then yeah i'm
just down the pawn
yeah maybe not that four was too early
i was excited about it too it's like
looking forward to a birthday
and then like no one shows up at your
birthday party
but life goes on
really
uh i have to take i guess
okay let's just play quick
this is a really difficult position
i'm trying to survive put the king here
really
that's funny that's probably really
strong too
[Music]
hmm
not looking good i'm gonna get the pawn
all the way
to somewhere
i want the rook on g3
more active rook
oh dirty [ __ ] that was a really dirty
flag
there was so many bad moves there look
at white's pawns too
from triple pawns man
i should have the chat open
okay that was the first like real dirty
flag
but that's the nature of no increments
um i'll play a london again
my score is pretty good with london um
idea knight f3
so i actually prepared this first
fiddler because swiveler plays a like a
similar line
sometimes he's played this in mantra
blitz
and the main idea is to meet d5 with
queen b3
trying to remember the full prep
because there's some bishop e5 idea
i know it's queen b3 first
i prepared this for swiddler months ago
and then
no one ever plays this and he didn't
play it
um
yeah i think it's bishop e5 here i know
it looks crazy
because knight a6
how does this work or is it knight b5
bishop b5 takes
maybe i'm just confusing myself
i really thought there was some bishop
b5 idea but maybe not
i should not have spent so much time
there
um maybe queen a4
idea of this i just want to trap the
queen
get the knight to c6 also this is a
threat now
so there's bishop d6
okay i don't know what black is doing
to the uh to stop knight c6 maybe bishop
b7
uh but then the pawn hangs
i guess there's a line like bishop b7
takes rook
a8 takes i don't know if i want to lose
my queen like that
okay rook before i did not see coming
it's really funny though i could just
take this and trap the queen
uh let's do it i could also
[Music]
what's the best approach here yeah i
think i'll just take it
i'm winning the exchange basically
assuming i'm not oh i overlooked
i overlooked um this knight c5 move
maybe it's not so bad
maybe it is really bad though
how bad is this on the rook
oh maybe it's not so bad because like um
oh i didn't see that move
wait now i'm up to exchange
i have this in queen d1
okay
at some point i'll have to go back and
analyze that
because that was uh there's potentially
interesting variation
all right so let's stay focused let's
actually keep the tension
i'll play this in this
maybe f3 the safety first
controlling e4
giving a square for my bishop as well
and play f4 and depositional
oh bishop h4 is not possible f4 is just
a bad move
knight h8 is the second time this match
knight h8 is played
so i kind of have a dead bishop
but i am of the exchange that's a good
move
queen h5
so tying down the g pawn to the knight
we're both trying to push our g pawns
interesting
um butchering this
oh okay another time scramble that
wasn't so clean
i spent a lot of time earlier in the
game but i got the job done
okay let's repeat the same opening
and he might want to mix things up queen
e2 hmm
i really just want like one staffer
gambit accepted
but we might not see it oh it's before
an idea
i actually vaguely remember this line i
don't think it's so dangerous
okay white's not going for it anyway
um i'll play a5 this time and bishop e3
i'll probably play
just d6
okay in this position probably castle
and d5
because i'm not concerned about this
pawn i want to open up the center
given i have a lead in development i'm
castled
white only has like a queen and knight
developed
and probably queen d6 here
actually now queen d6 doesn't work
because it takes
so i'll probably
yeah i'll start by taking
and then worst case scenario i always
have this move
like c4 coming
it's hard to actually punish white here
or d1 coming to
yeah these positions require like a lot
of precision
i'm going to play this move i know it
looks sad or you spent way too much time
making this move in knight a5
bishop g2 and castling is probably
expected or not
okay so now that h5 actually looks
enticing because if takes takes takes i
lose a pawn
um i have knight d3 in the end probably
got the bishop pair
and then like a castle i guess there's
queen e2 in the end
maybe queen c2 nice having a pawn on a4
also if if this pawn goes away the fifth
rank opens up for the rook
which could be relevant
meanwhile if if white doesn't go for
this line i have knight of four ideas
it's a nice square and it failed the
previous
game so this game i want to try and make
up for it
so we're going into the line i mentioned
yeah now if the light moves i i can take
e4
if castling i win h3
i guess i should be slightly like
careful about my queen
but the queen's not getting trapped that
queen's actually very strong here
so point wants to play f5
everything takes rook b1 takes f5
i bishop a2 there
okay let's go for this
wow so light sagging all the pawns
i'm gonna be greedy
so many free pawns
free rook almost didn't see that
both so focused on free pawns
okay still have to be a little bit
careful
um on my time
be very careful
so f5 i have queen e5 a nice inclusion
[Music]
um
because i'm up a whole rook but i'm down
on time
i can take and force the trade
yeah this just simplifies a2
bishop e5
i should make a looft at some point or
not okay
that was a nice game let's go again
so just want to keep keep trying to play
good moves
i've only lost one game so the london
has has
proven me well this will be the first
non-london game
and c5 is uh is an anti-london
and 96.
so i have one idea in this line is that
after nio6 i can play e5
i remember studying this a while ago
um okay now i'm i'm out of my prep
i think just bishop e3
i'm probably threatening to take and
then take and castle queenside with
check
a lot of potential for initiative and
chandralu
chan chandler i see there's a long
message
which i don't have time to read but
thanks for the bits
um there will be a break after the blitz
portion
okay so knight b5 is actually
interesting
knight b5
the queen b6
i'll just play bishop c4
anton thanks for the bits
yeah i think at this point like i was
looking for ways to punish black but
should just focus on basic principles
and funk bros
thanks for subbing looks like a new sub
b4 is an idea actually b4
oh i didn't have b4 because knight a4
now i'm threatening b4
um b4 before night b7
i'm not sure how great that is for me
i'll just castle
okay so defending the bishop creating
the battery ibmer
t y now that's a message i can
i can read fully thanks for the the
seven dollars
oh maybe for for seven wins i appreciate
that
yeah lucky number seven
have to enjoy this number while it lasts
okay before so i'm threatening b4 knight
here and then probably takes
because takes takes and um
i maybe went upon in that line i mean v
pawn would be hanging
so black undevelops
[Music]
i think knight d4 this is very
sicilian-like
but it feels like a sicilian up so many
tempe
oh but this pawn is attacked
i don't really want to play defensively
bishop f4 is actually kind of a cool
move
i think i'll do it it's probably really
dubious
i'm gonna do it so i'm throwing e5 i'm
allowing black to play e5
the idea is knight d5
and then i still might end up losing a
piece
but it looks fun
yeah there's just bishop e7 here so the
thought was a knight can come to c6
um and hopefully there's compensation
the other thought was that this line
like black's gonna have to think a lot
and even if it's objectively bad for me
um
hopefully it can can lead to a time
advantage which it is
i didn't lose a piece still some idea of
b4
f4 is also a typical move i'll play f4
first
preventing f4 from black and now fixing
the pawn here
and now
i think this is okay because if after
takes takes takes there's queen c2
okay between
f2
time is very good position is very good
too
i'm just cement the knight yeah this is
just positional heaven
idea to rook lift take that oh there's a
funny move
oh it doesn't work black has a bishop
almost both has gamuted there
that would have been really bad
um get the pawn to c4
good move
let's writing made in one also
threatening this
black played some good moves towards the
end there
okay so that's nine nine games
um i guess two more in this portion
and then we'll play bullet alright let's
play
i'll just stick with the same opening
i've had matches in the past where
like i like to mix it up but i like
every game i'm playing the same
repertoire
okay so so one of my most recent youtube
videos i
i showed this line my phone's having
none of it though
so maybe we won't see a like a staffer
gamut accepted
which is kind of sad
yeah we're getting many of the same
positions
and i want to punish this move but i'm
not sure how
maybe h5 some experimentation
and i will reroute and i'll have i'll
have this square maybe eventually this
square
this is kind of like a reverse
what do we call a black line like this
general setup
which i've never specifically studied
i mean it kind of resembles an italian
but the bishop is just kind of passive
no offense to the bishop
because i've had italian games with the
same structure where the bishop is here
which is maybe a better square
i should keep in mind this move
uh also this move
taking with queen is actually really
attractive
i don't know though let's try it
i feel loose i feel like i can i can
probably get away with more
more than usual
f5 let's preserve the bishop first
and then i think my ideal setup is
knight g6 bishop here queen here
the pawn will be defended there will be
a battery
and knight f4 okay it's not happening
i mean v5 is power knight e3 coming
let's just develop in bishop g2 i have
knight h4
oh but then i lose a queen but maybe
it's interesting
what would nezha medina do
oh it's such a cool queen sack
let's do it queen sack time botes gambit
but there's going to be a lot of
compensation oh there's knight d6 as
well
96 was maybe slightly stronger
now this might not even be bad for me it
probably is
but it might not be idea there's so many
ideas here
the bishops are breathing fire this is
kind of a fork
i guess white's just intentionally
allowing this
if i take i can probably get a way of
taking because if the bishop takes
well the rook might take actually i was
thinking if bishop takes i take the rook
rook here f6
i probably should have taken the rook
unless let's play f6 first
oh thanks for the bits cole welcome back
hole
let's play this move
so basically i have two minors for a
queen
i have the f3 square oh this is looking
nice
so i'm gonna win the rook i'm gonna have
a pass h pawn two h2 is really hard oh
it's easy to stop
let's preserve the bishop idea this is
this
because like the king is a the main
target
and bishop f3 is such a nice square and
this bishop is about to
do some damage
king g3 maybe the best try
i'll think oh oh that was a bad move aye
let's play this
unintentional sacrifices and then
c6 and then this move
i still have casting rights right
i'll push the pawn first it's never too
late to castle
what is this where's my mate
where's my mate
mate okay let's just play
bishop g5
check my meat
i don't see the mate oh there's there's
a flag okay that was a weird game
and it was a fun game though it's fun to
have initiative like that
even when you're down the queen oh
thanks for subbing
uh pat pat's patches wrench
um i'll play knight f3
and then e3 okay so this is not quite a
london but this is my prep against the
nimsovich
idea bishop b5 assuming black develops a
bishop
the first time i discovered this move
was
australia 2018 i prepared this for a
game
we didn't go into it
oh e5 might be coming
e5 is interesting
okay
so i probably want to go for queen b3
trying to figure out the right order
like maybe a3 first play a3 first
supports future b4
a6 is very reasonable
i'll play queen a4 so this is one of the
main ideas is to
i just pressure the knight if bishop d6
i play c5
so i do allow this the hope is that
i have some play on the g file
maybe f4 here
i don't know what i'm gonna do with my
king maybe castle queenside
i might just stay in the center i mean
this is a nice pawn setup
it's not easy for the center files to
open
this bishop will be happy this bishop on
the other hand
so i might want to play b4 like queen c2
bishop b2
i should also know that black takes
probably have to take with queen because
bishop takes b5
whoa b5 instantly so it's probably a
pawn sack
i'm assuming the ideas might be four
might be four queen
at a five wow
so i have pawn oh pawn b4 still knight
b3
i'm very nifty
maybe just bishop d3
uh definitely feeling some pressure here
let's have another free pawn
i mean can't argue with free pawns
knight p3 oh i'm going to lose stuff
back
at least i'm losing like the really
depressing bishop
black probably won't take it the knight
is just going to stay here
and d4 might be coming going after this
bishop and my queen
hopefully queen c2
good move
okay we're about to find out how bad
this is
i said earlier that it's hard for the
center files to open
but my opponent is finding a way
i mean the good thing is that if we
trade so many pieces
oh okay i have to play this move
if we trade pieces and it's harder for
black to mate me
this is terrifying in this pawn
i'm up on time not getting mated
good move so there's a tricky trick
oh it doesn't work though
play and what to do here
queen e5 maybe threatening meat
this is so terrifying
it was a bad decision
oh there goes my rook
and my queen
oh and my rook
please tell me please
ah
i tried good game oh
is it break time i think it's break time
i've only played really well that game
um
yeah i really regretted i guess the the
sender files are still technically okay
guys thank you very much there's gonna
be a break here five minutes or so
before we switch over to the bullets
action
okay sounds good
okay um i forgot i was on a zoom call
i guess i'll use this oh muted
okay good i'll use this opportunity to
open the chat
hi chat how's it going i had the chat
closed the whole time
but thanks for subbing uh the undersync
oh under the sink the under sink
um something with prime
and yeah so far i mean the match isn't
over
um this was just a blitz portion so
the next portion is 10 bullet games
oh how old was i when i got my im title
um 20
21 i think 21 or 20.
it was 2015. i got it
actually the same month i was the same
month as my birthday
i got in september i think it was after
my birthday
yeah so i've been in i am for about five
years
hey it's potzer play what's up potter
play
making our lives easier
whose lives oh oh yeah this is part of
like a team
so i actually i should know the format
pots are play can probably explain but
um i think this this match
goes towards some like overall match
between florida and chicago
so chicago represent even though i'm in
st
louis currently
when's my birthday a lot of people were
were sending me like birthday donations
a couple days ago
but it wasn't it's not my birthday until
until september
september 3rd so a few weeks away
yeah i'm not 30 but i'm a i'm a future
30 year old
hopefully
i'm also a former teenager
anyway what should i be doing with this
break
um i guess i can keep chatting okay guys
um you do have the right to call one
time out during the bullet section let
me just remind you guys um but other
than that
you can get started i don't know how
long the break has been but
okay sounds good
okay well i guess that was a break oh
hello to azerzev
welcome thanks for being a mod yeah i
hope people are behaving
themselves good to have at least one mod
here
um so
okay bowl of chess let's try and get in
some
some sort of focus mode
um so basically i need to win
i think two games to clinch the match
but i just want to play as good as
possible for the team
oh my is my opponent offline no so
challenge
and then one minute okay
so streaming so yeah streaming and
playing bullet
is difficult so i might um especially
serious bullet
so there might be less commentary
he's going to play hippo
um i know g4 or g3 is coming
yeah i saw his one of his previous
matches he played something like this
this bishop's attacked
let's move back
this f4 square like every game i'm black
it's such a juicy square
okay with trades don't really want to
trade queens but
it's not so bad i'm losing the pawn
um play rook f6 and g5
preserve the knight i'm losing another
pawn
but maybe winning a pawn i don't know
i'm losing all my pawns not the best
game oh the free rook
oh free bishop let's check first
okay that was nice
meat should be coming momentarily
okay that was a messy game it was a
great like middle game opening for me
and then i
kind of collapsed because then my
opponent gave me a rook
okay london time again oh hippo again
probably
so the best way to meet the hippo is to
push the rook pawns
weirdly enough let's go for this
i'm clicking f1 because i want my work
on h1
so no castle in this game
and queen h5 ideas
oh dye plunger i kind of blundered play
queen h5 anyway
make things a little bit tricky
c7 is attacked
a good move
what's going on here
go after this pawn
not a great position on a lot of things
and down on time
maybe coming back
okay i feel so dirty that was really
really bad time scramble
okay let's play one of these again
it's afro gamma time let's go hey it
actually happened
kind of um
and black's actually playing a good line
i can deal with this still some
some sort of compensation
kind of maybe not
let's play this move yeah white's
handling this really well
c5 to defend the rook
am i night trapped my night's trapped
sadly
but truthfully i need this move
no
there's my tricks play this move
ah night this is really really bad
[Music]
tactics it doesn't work though
it does it
does it where's my meat
it's so close to meat
oh man oh the king almost got mated
i don't know if i i may have missed mate
there i don't know
so i officially won the match which is
nice play e4
first time okay let's go for this again
yeah this is kind of a slow play
game
and
i might need to take a timeout by losing
my voice
probably just a sign i should stop
talking
this is not good
or is it oh this is really bad
oh this is really bad
but actually really bad
it's still fighting
there goes my queen and my king
let's not do that again also let's
prepare like every game hippo
also let's repeat this opening never
mind
okay scotch game
hmm
this is a very thematic idea
okay let's go for this i could sack the
queen like last game
let's not do that too soon though
yeah i'm happy with the queen trade
because that means i'm not getting mated
so soon
you should probably play quicker
oh let's check oh man
this is not the best quality chess
let's try and fight though
here's my king oh meeting attack maybe
dirty flagging coming
yes stalemate okay oh
should have lost that but okay
what to do play d4 again
preventing the hippo i'll just treat
this like a london
running this oh c7 can't really be
defended
okay now i can take on g7
[Music]
probably just take here
this is very pleasant
very feel good opening
i don't think this is too much to worry
about
and there's should be five ideas
um so maybe it is something to worry
about
play this in rook b1
okay now i'm beginning to worry let's
simplify
i have a night light should be enough
that keeps the king safe
i'll play this move develop
the king put the knight on b3 and then
on c5
interesting
my opponent is definitely like
resourceful
okay yeah black definitely resisted
there after like such a good opening
all right let's repeat this
g4 what is g4
so there's a trap takes and then bishop
f2
i'm hanging this but maybe something
good will happen
maybe maybe not
uh oh okay i'm threatening this
i cut off the bishop from defending but
i am losing a rook
so what's going on um
queen wants to come to g1
take on g5
i'm just confused what's going on here
okay let's just keep pushing pawns
i can take this
i think this is force mate the bishop
got stuck in the corner
if king takes it's made in two with
queen takes it's
uh made in two nice
okay i'm losing track so
the score has to add up to 21.
interesting
okay so we basically have a reverse like
b3
oh i plundered kind of maybe not as
knight g6 bishop g6
so i'd like to play c4 at the right
moment waiting for queen e7
one doesn't go for that so idea
probably take that castle
it's a pleasant position idea rook g3
thanks for subbing lich something
something
uh it's not plundering knights
oh that's a tricky move
okay so we just traded
bishop wants to enter this diagonal
a very weird structure
i don't know what my plan is what's my
plan
my plan should be not to flag
that was a good move oh that was a good
move too
wow
many games are coming down to these
these scrambles
i feel bad
i also feel good let's play walrus
i'm assuming g4 is coming at some point
so i want to play knight h4
um just develop the bishop
okay i'd rather open the file let's
start with f6
restricting the knight or even
even a5
um
[Music]
it's close to working
i'll play f5 first and then prepare e4
so we're basically trading knights
idea d4
log 94 this is pleasant
and things are under control
at some point maybe rook b6
oh the thing was hanging
okay this is looking fine
the bishop is pinned and attacked about
to be attacked four times
okay and time i didn't even know this
time the time was very good that game
so this is the last game can i do math
uh yeah so this is the last game
um i studied this did i study this
d4 uh i'll play c4
i don't know if i studied this out of my
prep already
but we're getting some position
um this is probably like just not great
for me
especially with the the bishop situation
great bishop versus terrible bishop
but i'm alive
i have f4 here
now this move could hurt me it can be
one i was going to say d6 is weak but
not anymore
hmm wait this is the final game i don't
want to lose
let's try and fight
i'm going for something it doesn't work
it really doesn't work
it really doesn't work oh dear
pawn storm time
ah here's all my pieces
checkmate
gotta play it out
yes that's a fitting ending
it's a very fitting ending okay
uh i feel i feel bad about feeling good
about that
anyway people can use a stalemate emote
and i think there will be a post game
interview
oh thanks so much aaron pilgrim the
blitz and bullet bits
all right guys uh what a match um eric
congratulations that was a pretty uh
convincing win
oh thanks so much yeah a lot of games
came down to
these uh these dirty time scrambles
yeah it really felt like you had the
advantage when it comes to uh comes to
the time situation there
um do you just feel like you're just
really fast at playing a lot of blitz
and bullet
yeah i've definitely been playing a lot
more recently
it can be hard to especially like when
streaming
to talk and play bullets but um
but yeah i've been getting my practice
in
i heard a rumor that uh i know this is
true but john do you use a
touchpad when you play oh okay
yeah i used to use a touchpad too but i
think uh
sometimes it can slow slow you down a
little bit
yeah and jan and i were actually talking
about during our stream that you know
we're really impressed how you're able
to you know stream and actually speak
and stuff like that while playing
blitz and bullet because i mean it feels
like that's probably something you have
to
you know learn a little bit as a skill
because otherwise you get a little bit
distracted
oh yeah i know it's it's not easy um
especially when i first started
streaming
just the concept of multitasking i think
it leads to a lot more blunders
but um i just try and be vocal with my
inner thoughts
um and sometimes like in at least in
blitz it can help
because then i'm held accountable to
actually like continually think and
calculate
yes and john john
did you feel like you know you started
out you won one of the early games there
um i think it was game two but then eric
really went on a very uh
you know long run did you feel like you
were getting tilted or maybe you're just
struggling a little bit but the time
situation at times
well so you know me i don't you know i
like playing different stuff especially
like online chess i don't play anything
orthodox i just play completely whack
stuff
and um i feel like eric was figuring out
a lot of what i do like florida players
can't figure out my stuff but eric was
figuring it out
which is annoying so um
i was trying to go into more normal
stuff later on the match but by then it
was kind of late
and i was kind of tilting by then so i
don't know it wasn't so much time
scrambles because like
i don't know i feel like i was just kind
of getting beat like in the middle game
yeah there were definitely several games
and and that's true i mean i played you
in a board match not too long ago and
you have a very sort of unorthodox style
you really like to keep a lot of pieces
on the board how did you
deal with that eric did you sort of
expect that and are you just comfortable
playing dynamic positions
i'll admit i i didn't do so much
preparation but i did see
i think the last match that john played
against uh
dalton and seemed like so many games
there was
this hippo set up um so i was definitely
expecting
i was actually expecting more of that in
the blitz
but i did a little bit of like just
general preparation of like looking at
positions where i push the
the a and h pawns early to to try and
punish
punish this hippo as much as possible um
and then i guess so the earlier games um
yeah it was nice just kind of sticking
with my my london repertoire
and like that first game uh featured
some some nice opening preparation
i think that's pretty much the exact
line that you beat me in it right i
think that's right yeah it was funny
that you you had mentioned that
uh i think i should have prepared john
at the start of the call
yeah uh but yeah i think that's theory
quite quite a long way there
um yeah but yeah we didn't notice that
in the first game you played this um
let's sit out so we assumed he probably
had seen that john likes to go for the
c3 g3 stuff
uh but then john it felt like you were
getting into it a little bit in the
bullet section you won two games in a
row i think you missed made in one in
that
game we then ended up stalemating in the
middle there and after that maybe
did you start selling a little bit more
we felt like after that you played a
couple games with some very wild opening
stuff like that
um
i don't know i mean bullet i don't play
anything normal so
i don't know it's it's like if i lose
half the time it's just because the
opening i play
you know i don't even think it's like
i mean i'm probably like minus two out
of the opening as white
so i mean i don't know
yeah and that last game was definitely
crazy there we uh we've had a lot of
people freaking out at that stalemate
and it's a very unusual stalemate there
the kingston d7 but yeah just almost
being taken up that was kind of a crazy
way to finish the match off
yeah yeah i don't want a flag like yeah
when you use a touchpad you're just kind
of like
you're going full qual quantity over
quality like you don't even care about
what moves you play it's like
you just gotta move cause there's
there's no room for error with the
touchpad unfortunately
all right john next time we're playing
i'm buying you a mouse that's settled
no i already have a mouse but i don't
know
all right sounds good i mean what mouse
are you using
yes so i'm using a mouse that i didn't
actually buy myself it just kind of came
with this apartment when i moved in this
is uh this is a chess bra mouse it's
like a logitech
something i don't know the exact model
but
it feels good i've gotten used to it we
have like a giant mouse pad
so you can use the whole desk as a mouse
or as a
kind of mouse pad basically all right
well very nice uh thank you so much guys
it really was some entertaining chess
there were always a lot of uh
you know attacks going above both direct
positions once again putting your team
in an excellent position with that 16-5
win
putting chicago up but there are 12
matches still to go will be played
played over the next week so a lot of
interesting chess
to look forward to there thank you guys
so much cool thank you
appreciate it this was exciting to watch
and commentate so
for sure yeah yeah so the next match
will be tomorrow night
um at uh 7 p.m and it's going to be
hosted over on the national blitz league
channel
um so check that one out um also make
sure to follow eric's channel as well i
am rosen
um always a lot of great content there
we will probably be doing some florida
commentary as well for some of these
matches
but the next uh two days are gonna be
hosted on national bits league so
tomorrow at 7 pm is the next one
thank you so much guys for for tuning in
and eric and john for playing and guys